anthony smith he's on food truck on  tuesday hopefully he doesn't lose here's  the thing fellas  i need anthony smith to get a win and  not get hurt okay we need anthony swift  to win this and not get hurt i like this  guy i like i like how tatted up he is i  like his stance right now like he's got  a firm solid  stance but he knows it's not just other  guys  these daggers dude they are taking over  combat sports why do you say that well  because it's probably tough no they grow  up but they grow up they have their  support of combat they grow a chuff they  grow up doing it oh it's like it's like  three hundred yeah they're gross they're  like spartans  they have beers  this is sparta five minutes later  anthony smith broke his ankle that's  what he said  was that with a little [ __ ] yeah  it can't be good for boot drive oh [ __ ]  yeah bro stop being so selfish jesus  broke his ankle [ __ ] you can't come on  my youtube show  he doesn't like your shoulders  you